[Applause]
hi
[Applause]
how are you oh gosh what a
heavy question today um how am i i'm
really sad
true i'm sad is the overwhelming emotion
that i feel
um you know i am
just uh so achingly sad
that we had insurrectionists
um storm our capital you know it hadn't
happened since 1814
since the war of 1812 when kind of the
the british invaded
our country and that we had
white nationalist terrorists effectively
overwhelm our capital
terrorize our elected you know men and
women of congress
our capital police um you know
defame and deface you know the capitol
building
loot the capitol building you know
in wearing camp auschwitz sweatshirts
and waving confederate flags
it's just horrifying to me and then
trying to explain what
was happening to our children um
i'm very sad i'm very sad today i mean i
am incredibly
grateful and proud that joe biden and
kamala harris will indeed be
our next president vice president of the
united states and i am
holding that pride kind of deep in my
heart and my soul
um and yet i'm also still really sad
really sad to me
i um was listening to uh van jones
who said something that i've been
holding on to
where he said is this the end of
something
or the beginning of something and we
make that choice right now
and because i am such an
optimist uh but a realist uh you know i
don't think in this time anymore we can
have
optimism that's just blind and giddy
we have to have optimism that's rooted
in grounded reality
and civic awareness
do you think that this can be
a turning point and the beginning
of i certainly watched all the senators
last night speak on both sides
and i want to be always inclusive to
both sides i'm not a party person i'm
a humanist and to see
temperatures calmed as so many people
have hoped for do you think that's
possible
now in the wake of this i think
you know drew the answer to your
question is at the beginning of the
question
right it's it's possible if we make it
possible and certainly
you know i was up really late last night
too watching all of
the proceedings on the senate and the
house floor
and and was similarly really
reassured to see you know mitt romney
and kind of the republicans who really
were putting you know country over over
party and kind of being being patriotic
after a day of
kind of very much the opposite on on
display
in the hallowed halls of our capital um
and
and i do think you know we we have to
ensure that um this is the end of
something and it's the end of not only
you know a handful of years in which
hate was
kind of mainlined into our kind of
national
conversation and somehow allowed to
become acceptable
in which we have seen you know huge
rises in hate crimes against
black americans jewish americans muslim
americans women
you know often um aided abetted egged on
by by our president and so i do think
you know we have to ensure that this is
the end of
the end of something but it's also has
to be the end of
you know 400 years of um
white supremacy in our country and the
fact that we saw
confederate flags in the capital
um yesterday is hopefully just such a
call
that we you know have to ensure that we
are
um we are moving forward and that we're
moving forward honestly
and i think what you said was so
beautiful true that you're uh
you're an optimist but you're also a
realist you know i i'm just thinking so
much today about how we teach
history how we teach civics uh in our
country and i think we have to do a much
better and more honest job i think um
i think so much about credit scott king
was one of the original inspirations for
me kind of writing the she persisted
series
and um she spoke so
frequently and emphatically urgently
about how progress has to be protected
and defended in each generation and i
think we're really living in a moment
where we
have to protect the progress that we've
made and we have to keep keep pushing
forward
um in our country because we clearly
have
a tremendous amount of of work to do
both to remedy injustice and also to
ensure
that um hate it doesn't have a home here
and doesn't have a platform here
reading this book uh while
simultaneously
watching what was happening last night
and we'll spend our second segment
focused on this extraordinary book
was such an incredible juxtaposition to
what was happening in our current time
and i am in in
holding on to the faith that 2020 has
been
the volleyball that has been set up and
we will spike
in some extraordinary continued
change in our country the way we
treat people to demonstrate around the
world the humanity
that we have and and want to share with
each other and hold as the standard
[Music]
you